November 6 1814 in the belgian city of
de not and a modest house built on the
street that would later bear his name
Adolphe Sax was born 28 years later
while living in paris sachs would invent
the saxophone and revolutionized music
in ways he couldn't imagine but this
isn't that story this is the story of
coffee tough sack game death seven times
before mending the saxophone hardly old
enough to stand a young Adolf fell down
three flights of stairs stone floor
broke his fall the age of three it off
swallowed a bowl of water down sulfuric
acid mistaking it for milk years later a
dog on the rocks please too close to a
gunpowder explosion he was again burned
when a cast-iron frying pan was knocked
over on Later original Valens head
leaving a lifelong star
Edith McNeely asphyxiated and when
recently varnished items were left in
his bedroom overnight he woke up fairly
telling with friends in a nearby river
Adolf was swept up in his lips current
and nearly drowned again
he survived
[Music]
On February 7th 1894 a dog died
peacefully in Paris the saxophone had
already crossed the Atlantic trying to
evolve into an icon of American jazz
music and guaranteeing sax is
immortality
[Music]